les garçons, où êtes-vous allés,
regardez, nous sommes vraiment désolés. Splinter, certains
gars voulaient acheter une pizza et j'ai essayé
de l'en dissuader ouais, nous nous avons loués,
hé, n'utilisez pas ce mot de cette façon, je veux dire, nous sommes en
2023, papa,
hé les gars.  Si vous n'étiez pas des monstres
rejetés par la société et que nous pouvions faire ce que nous
voulions,
que feriez-vous, les gars, iriez-vous au lycée,
peut-être trouver une petite amie, il est peu probable que la
police soit déroutée par la récente
vague de criminalité menée par un Superfly, personne n'a jamais
vu son visage.  pourquoi parce qu'il détruit
tous ceux qui ne refroidissent pas
un peu cool
super amusant et puis tout le monde nous acceptera
un peu les tortues hein je ne peux pas croire qu'il y
ait d'autres mutants il est temps pour les
mutants de gouverner la Terre
ensemble
il n'y a rien que tu ne puisses accomplir à
l'étranger